live
uh so I uh this is Nick Gillespie this
is the reason live stream I'm joined
today by my reason colleague Natalie
nozicki hi Natalie hey happy to be here
is it doseki or dauseki you're here okay
yeah close enough for uh for
anti-government work and we're joined by
Eli Lake uh who is calling in from an
undisco undisclosed location
uh hello Eli thanks for joining us hi
Nick thanks for having me okay uh I want
to point out at the beginning that
Natalie and you are both from uh the
Philadelphia area and so you know we'll
factor that into Germantown you know
Europe
okay where are you from um I'm I'm from
outside King of Prussia oh oh my God
then you're not I mean that's like
Harrisburg right I thought you were
actually from Philadelphia
close enough yes no
um okay so we are uh this uh today uh we
are doing a live stream conversation for
about the next hour and we're it's going
to revolve around Kanye West who uh is
um you know one of the greatest musical
artists arguably a major player are in
fashion and particularly in streetwear
but definitely a major major recording
artist who has a bizarre history of both
challenging the conventional wisdom
particularly when it comes to racial and
political matters uh but also has a
history of mental illness which he's
talked about openly he's bipolar and he
actually absented himself from uh social
media for the better part of two years I
think right or 18 months not too long
ago because of that he's also he was
married to Kim Kardashian and which you
know I hate to put anything in terms of
Elizabeth Taylor and Richard Burton but
like it was as big a deal as that
um you know was in its day
um but we're going to talk about that I
guess first off uh Eli can you are uh
you are the host of the re-education
podcast yeah which is mostly about
politics but off also you talk about
popular culture including music you are
uh known to uh freestyle rap we're going
to put a moratorium on that uh for the
next hour what you do on your own
business is you know is your you know
you can do whatever you want but
um how big a deal is Kanye West as a as
a musician
well I think you have to he's in the
category in my TV
he turned himself into a serious rapper
but that's not really where his genius
is he's more of a kind of musical
Visionary
um and in that respect he's more than a
producer when you consider
the Breakthrough of the the precedent
that he set on albums like my Dark
Twisted beautiful fantasy which is kind
of like you could say hip-hop's you know
Sergeant Pepper or Abby Road except that
it's something we would actually want to
listen to from time to time your stoat
slander Abby wrote I I I'm here for part
of this yeah okay Mean Mr Mustard yeah
uh right the whole thing um but then you
know there's an album that didn't do as
well but it's called a it's called 808
and heartbreaks that was a record that
kind of invented Drake's
are half of Drake sound the kind of emo
um heavily modified synthesized singing
that he does on a lot of his work
um and that was a kind of that was that
was Kanye West coming up with that
before anybody else and in there and and
the and the fact that he has not limited
himself just to hip-hop he put out I
think some excellent gospel records
recently
um and you know he's a he's a towering
figure not as again not just as a
producer but I like to think of sort of
as a musical Visionary he is and he's
also somebody who's found Talent
um you know some of the first guest
appearances of Big Sean Nicki Minaj was
you know with young money but you know
her breakout was on a Kanye West single
um you know so in that respect he's a he
is a huge and enormous figure
um and I I'm trying to think if there
would be an equivalent uh you know in
other things but you know I mean maybe
like a David Bowie type on some level I
mean if they're all distinct but you
know where Bowie not only changed the
musical landscape for what he did but
then broke a lot of talent or you know
produced people and brought them to
larger audiences and really kind of
shifted the musical conversation
absolutely and the restlessness of Kanye
to constantly change style so when he
came out with a record called Jesus it
was almost like Industrial
you know it was it was very gritty it
wasn't really like a popular hip-hop
record but certainly not like anything
else that was coming out before it from
him or in the in the sense so he the
restlessness the fact that he's always
trying out new styles that was very OAS
in that respect so uh Natalie do you
have strong feelings about uh Kanye or
as I guess he's yay or ye he's ye now
right I don't know how to pronounce it
but um do you have strong uh strong
sensibility about him
I mean as a as an artist and well as a
musician and as an artist and as like a
cultural icon like we like we've already
hinted at I think it's it's hard because
the Kanye like I know and love or the
the Yi that um I know and love is like
from the stronger album and so like and
like his song's stronger just like was
such a cultural impact when I was like
younger and like when I I was in college
or high school and that's kind of what I
he's like always stuck in my brain as as
that musician which is like it's great
to see musicians evolve like this what
we've already talked about but like I I
kind of miss that version of him uh but
maybe that's just like for my my musical
preference
um but and more so than anything else
and if I'm I'm gonna flip the cards
you're 26 right I am yeah so you I mean
but you know it's distinct uh because
I'm much older than that I am uh 20
years 22 year years older 23 years older
than you so I grew up in the Rock era
and uh you are a hip-hop native Eli is
is a good bit uh he's somewhere in in
the middle of us
um but it's kind of fascinating to think
about this conversation just about
popular music Eli you know when you I
know you like hip-hop you like rap
you've kind of evolved into that for me
my kids do but it's a little bit distant
but I recognize the cultural force that
somebody like well I grew up with it I
mean I was I was like in elementary
school when
the first rap records really started
coming out in Philadelphia so I I know
from a very young age I used to listen
to Lady B's program on Power 99 when
hip-hop wasn't played on any other radio
stations except this one time slot on
Sundays
um so please tell me that you hung out
with Jazzy Jeff I wish in West
Philadelphia but I remember when I
remember
absolutely yeah and
uh I will say this when I was an intern
at Philadelphia magazine many years ago
I did one of the first interviews with
Quest love when he was with what they
were then calling themselves the square
roots before they were the roots and
they had a local pressed album called
Organics which is terrific if you can
find it
um the first it was right it was before
their first major label uh release of do
you want more but I mean the roots were
fantastic uh in this you know so
Philadelphia has a rich tradition
but yeah on in terms of Kanye there's
not really much like him he's had
several careers because he was a really
important
um he was an important producer
for Jay-Z and his later works you know
like he's all over the album The Black
Album and the blueprint those are really
important hip-hop records and if it was
just if it was if he was just the
producer who did that and other things
and worked with like diplomats and
Cameron and things like that you know
daino but then he decided he had to be a
rapper he wanted to be a star and he
kind of wheeled himself into this
position and and then you know as I said
he becomes kind of musical Visionary and
is gone beyond hip it's it's he's bigger
than just a hip-hop artist at this point
in my opinion he's bigger than the
Beatles were when they were bigger than
Jesus
uh you know not in his lifetime though
you know
Jesus is like Nick Drake or something
you know he's much bigger after he died
um so let's uh we have a couple Clips
but the reason we're talking about Kanye
West is you know I mean he's he's famous
because of his music uh somewhat because
of his dabbling in in fashion and
whatnot and and for marrying Kim
Kardashian who is kind of a fascinating
cultural force in her own and I like to
think of these people as all kind of
broadly libertarian in the sense that
they are highly individualistic in a
culture that oftentimes is antagonistic
to that and they you know they make they
have their reality Distortion fields
that are you know pretty amazing to
think about
um but without you know trying to layer
too much ideology onto any of this Kanye
recently gave a an interview to uh to
Tucker Carlson on Fox News where he
talked about a lot of things and we're
going to get to their comments where he
uh both uh on a social media accounts as
well as in unaired versions of the uh of
the Tucker Carlson interview that um
came to light through Vice
um where he ranges into anti-Semitism of
a particularly kind of classic version
within the black community
um we're going to talk about that but
let's play a clip first uh Natalie uh
would you uh uh lay uh start the uh
Trump clip from crazy to not be able to
say
that I like Trump
a drove because think about it's me
imagine me not being able to say what I
wanted was the point of being famous
what was the point of having you know
millions of people love your music what
was the point of having a voice if you
can't even use your own voice and
connect it to your own opinions yes
that's where the disconnect happened
that's where the
okay so I I you know by the way Tucker
Carlson I don't know uh you know I know
him a bit personally I used to be on his
old MSNBC show a while uh he is an
incredible performer whatever you think
about him he uh and staging this and
it's interesting when you look at what
he left out and what he left in because
it's a long like two-hour uh you know
two-part interview with Kanye West and
he left out the good parts right in many
ways like the most incendiary stuff but
let's focus first on this snippet
um and it recalls a while ago uh you
know when Trump emerged as a political
figure Kanye West was kind of friendly
to him he actually showed up he wore a
Maga hat and whatnot
um and then he kind of went silent how
do you how do you respond to him talking
about a kind of Orthodoxy in the
entertainment industry in Hollywood as
it were
um that kept him silent Eli
well in some ways
Kanye's attitude towards Trump after he
wins the election in 2016.
is the same as a lot of
Hollywood's reaction to Trump 10 years
before that
Trump I mean there's a song by Morris
Day and The Time called Donald Trump
Black Version
which is a pie on to Trump when he was
the Real Estate Mogul guy and this was a
song from like the very end of the 80s
um there you can watch Comedy Central
roast of Donald Trump and you'll find
all these celebrities who you know
they're needling him but he's part of
the club and that you know when Donald
Trump was and kind of not seen as a
political threat and just a celebrity
he gave money to like lots of Democrats
who ended up you know hating him he was
he was somebody who was sort of accepted
as fine he's in the club he's a rich guy
kind of a celebrity and everything else
um then you know when he takes on these
kind of very angry populist tone and
this becomes the kind of you know uh
wrecking ball of the political
establishment is when Trump in this
period and some of it is earned he
becomes toxic now I think Kanye in some
ways is looking around he's saying there
are all these things that now that I'm
like in this sort of elite club and that
he I think there's something about him
as an artist that he wants to
kind of touch whatever the third rail is
because he realizes that whatever people
are telling you whatever the shibboleth
is that you you can never you know
expose or never say that's probably
where the art is going to be so I sort
of see him that way we talked about this
on on when you were a guest with me on
punk rock but Kanye in a lot of ways is
embodying the spirit of punk
from the mid from 1975 1976 in that he's
whatever it is that is this sacred cow
in our culture that you're not allowed
to talk about you're not allowed to like
he's coming out there and like you know
making sure that you know that he's on
the other side of it and that to me it's
and so that's where I think that's
coming from so yeah he doesn't want to
be told what to think and who he
supports
that's all well and good but part of
that is very deliberate because that's
how Kanye kind of sees himself he's
gonna figure out like when he started
just to kind of put a circle ones one of
the things he fashion wise he did when
he when he came out with College Dropout
his first record so he deliberately
dressed in like Carlton of The Fresh
Prince like very preppy you know sweater
vests Argyle so and the reason he did
that is because everybody else in
hip-hop was wearing baggy jeans and
hoodies and everything else like that so
his point was like you know whatever use
when when you Zig I'm gonna zag and I'm
gonna do that deliberate
and it's I mean it's interesting to
think about when he first you know he uh
this was a few years ago but it was
wrapped up in the Trump stuff where he
was saying that uh you know he intimated
that slavery was a choice in in a kind
of strange interview uh that was very
electrifying and he basically was
arguing and echoing something Trump had
said which was that African-American
voters were being taken uh for granted
by the Democratic party or by liberals
uh who had not served them very well and
this was a trump talking point on the
campaign Trail uh a uh uh Kanye Protege
Chance the Rapper got into big trouble
when he said you know what like uh you
know when you look at the way the police
and the schools are run in Chicago his
home City you know we shouldn't be
voting for Democrats and he ended up
walking that back
um so there's that kind of antinomianism
of pushing back I guess Natalie I was
gonna say too like this is someone who
has always been known for like not
wanting to follow the script right so
like I don't think this like is
necessarily surprising like him being
liking Trump isn't like a surprising
like turn of events as I think like
people seem to be very surprised in 2018
like this is someone who's like very
much tries to fight The Narrative he's
oh he's been in the spotlight his whole
life
um and even more so in the last decade
because of um his very public family and
very public uh well I guess now
technically divorced maybe not uh uh
marriage but I think part of it too is
like I think it was back in 2005
or uh he said something about like
George W bush not caring not caring
about black people right because of like
the place and yeah I mean it's remember
this is the same guy who like shouldered
uh uh Taylor Swift off this page at an
award ceremony kind of like the way that
black lives activists shouldered Bernie
Sanders off the stage at a campaign
event in 2016. uh continue Natalie yeah
and he's just always been someone that's
like been provocative right and I think
if if that's like his that's his Mo and
that's always been his Mo so from the
Trump from his perspective on Trump it's
not all that surprising
um but I do think like after learning
about like the mental health struggles
he could be having or has been having
for quite some time
um it makes him a little bit more
um
even more controversial I would say
um because they're there are now two
camps that wanted to Mis dismiss what he
says entirely because of um his mental
illness he came out I believe it was in
2018
um and uh told everyone that he was
bipolar um so everyone kind of just uses
that now to Discount a lot of the
quote-unquote crazy or crazy stuff you
said since then
um so can I add or can I ask you you
know what's interesting uh you know and
in these moments he reminds me even more
than of David Bowie uh uh Bob Dylan of
like you know Dylan in this you know at
various points you know turns on his
audience or you know it's widely
interpreted as turning on his audience
first folk rockers he goes electric I
think the most amazing one was you know
at the end of the 70s the Me decade a
decade of you know swinging and sex
parties he becomes a born-again
Christian in no uncertain terms Kanye
West is kind of doing that
um so there's that but then the question
Natalie and any lie is why didn't he
speak up sooner because if he thrives on
telling people to go [ __ ] themselves why
was he silent for so long that's that's
I mean in the interview he seemed to be
suggesting that he was getting threat
like
like threats of violence
um especially like from close like
friends of his like from Kris Kardashian
I remember me I mean apparently she has
a lot of a lot of power I don't keep up
with them but you know
um I think I think he was more
intimidated which is also confusing
because he didn't really seem as someone
that could be easily intimidated uh but
I think too like there's a there's a
large aspect too with his kids getting
involved in like his drama and I think
um from the Carlson interview like like
you said I ran two hours plus because we
got unedited versions as well
um and I think he seemed to be worried
about like his his kids because those
came up multiple times like he was
worried about coming out in support of
trump in fear of like the retaliation
against hit against him and his career
being over
um quote unquote but also like what
would happen like retaliation against
his children
um do you think that explains his
silence Eli like
no
um it's possible I think it's
it's a reflection of
it's very different in into five after
Hurricane Katrina when he said George W
bush doesn't like
uh black people in that it was you know
Hollywood was liberal and George W bush
wasn't popular with you know a lot of
people in the music industry
but it was it didn't feel like it was
really who was was he popular with
anyone I mean maybe like Dave Mustaine
of mega death or something but I mean I
I he was popular with uh with Kid Rock
oh okay that's true thank you he was Kid
Rock was a republican
um but the point is is that it was not
seen that there were you couldn't be a
conservative we were in a very different
place we
it's Kanye's kind of you want to call it
his red pilling
it happens in a moment in our country
when you know there's enormous social
pressure on anyone who expresses
opinions that are in any way deviating
from what are seeing as like almost
moral imperatives in a way where it was
before it was like it was okay like
they they're cool people in the culture
cultural Elites were not Republicans or
conservatives in 2005.
but nobody cared if you were making a
movie and there was an actor who you
knew to be a conservative was on you
know what I'm saying there wasn't
pressure that was brought to bear or
Kevin Sorbo had not yet been fully
blacklisted by Hollywood yeah or like
you know remember I mean Mark Stein was
a was a staff writer for the Atlantic
and nobody cared because it was it was
understood that you could have you know
yeah not everyone's going to agree and
so he can so he he says that about
Hurricane Katrina he doesn't really
become this gadfly until that we have
this change in the culture where certain
people think that words are violence and
that we have to de-platform people who
have
you know political views that are
harming people and things like that
that's when I think something clicks
with Kanye
um and also it's possible it's quite
possible that his his uh his bipolar uh
issues yeah worsened uh and maybe they
they they're sometimes manageable and
then he's not taking medicine and
they're worse so that might be an
explanation too I want to just add one
more thing wouldn't it be perfect from a
kind of cultural karma for George W bush
at an award show to say Kanye West
doesn't like Jewish people
wouldn't that be like the perfect
symmetry at this point I don't know you
know I that's a it's a great plan but
what awards program is going to invite
George W bush maybe like the Saudi
Arabian khashoggi Awards democracy uh
anti-disinformation Awards
uh yeah it is true that uh Bush who left
office I think with the lowest approval
ratings uh he had lower approval ratings
than when Nixon left exactly um yeah and
um you know started climbing in the
public imagination or in the public
memory As Trump you know was uh was
soldiering on as president
um so all of this there's a little bit
of a precedent here too where it's it's
about the the the the craziness of our
particular moment because you know Bowie
In the late 70s got in trouble for
fascist iconography and also for
literally saying something and this is a
paraphrase but it's pretty close that
fascism is the only proven effective
form of government okay he was yeah so
he was saying that and it's not like
people said I'm not gonna buy scary
monsters and then
um you know Eric Clapton famously you
know had that crazy speed-free endorsed
Enoch Powell who is this you know
reactionary anti-immigration and and
that kind of those kinds of politics and
you know there was Rock Against Racism
where people you know wanted to but it
wasn't like Eric Clapton was ostracized
and said you know we're never gonna like
play your music again because that's not
because we had an appreciation
in the 70s and the 80s and that there
were going to be that artists could have
extreme points of view but it didn't
affect the quality of their art and you
know we weren't going to go that far
it's only now that these are live issues
again which is crazy it's like we're
we're back to the Anthony Comstock era
um but let's let's go deep on this a
little bit uh you know because you know
this is the question then right uh you
know should you separate the artist from
the art or what what level do you or
what point do you because I think we all
do
um you know we have to right
um so what is your sense how close does
uh you know how close are we to having
that happen now and I think you're right
to say we're you know the cultural
moment has changed since you know
whatever we are in 2022 it's different
than it was in 2002.
um and it's kind of refreshing to
remember that
um you know that and it's different than
82 or 62 or whatever but you know
Natalie would you I mean like are any of
the things that Kanye is saying and like
I I would not even consider like oh you
know he's pro-trump so I won't listen to
his music that seems nuts
um the anti-semitic stuff and some of
the other things he's talked about are a
little bit worrying and also indications
of a kind of delusional mode that he's
in you know he's also talked about
becoming president and it's not clear
that he is either joking or speaking
figuratively
um and I'm uncomfortable you know kind
of consuming work by people who seem to
be obviously insane saying
um but I mean Natalie has he you know
when when what would he have to do to
cross the line for you
uh I don't want to I don't want to give
him any
um okay so but part of it I think
part of it is like of course I'm gonna
it's personal preference and in my
opinion like I don't I don't care if
someone if you're an actor if you're a
singer and you have a specific political
party that you agree with and you make
that public like good for you like I
don't have to agree with your politics
to listen or dance to your music
um but I do think it gets to a line
where it's it's too hard to separate
like you were just saying it's too hard
to separate the performer and their work
um from their like personal Antics and
um I think it's it's very clear and Nick
and I were discussing this beforehand
but it's very clear to me and especially
with the uh the unaired clips that um
Vice pulled out as well that
um
Tucker Carlson was trying to show a a
Kanye that looked like he should be a
conservative conservative icon
um but then in the extra bits from the
interview that we saw he you know he's
very erratic in some of his answers
um he said even some even like very
offensive
um anti-semitic uh phrases and I just
think it's I almost fell I felt almost
like scummy going back and re-watching
the interview in the sense that like I
now have like the context I didn't
originally have that the Tucker Carlson
show chose to cut out now does that have
anything to do with me liking Kanye's
music
um do I think that he should like I
guess it was reported yesterday do I
think that he should no longer be able
to hold his money at JP Morgan because
of this
um and those types of like extra like uh
the woke mob clearly coming for him
um I think that's a different question
but I do think I do think him supporting
Trump isn't isn't crossing the line of
like oh we should no longer listen to
his music or we should shun him
um but I do think he's he's towing a
line but but I think you can't forget
about the other like personal mental
illness problems that are going on in
his life
um Eli what about you is there uh you
know what's the Rubicon uh what's the
river of the river that is foaming with
blood
if you go historically Ezra pound was an
open supporter of the Nazis during World
War II and actually he preferred
Mussolini his propaganda
specifically
in the great battle against the fascists
yeah we had radio programs which were
horrible and uh does that take away from
the Brilliance of his poetry of course
not
um but does it make you more or less
likely I mean have you when is the last
time you cracked open the cantos well I
mean doesn't it tip you to being like
why I'm a little bit of a deep dive on
James Jesus Angleton you had a
relationship so it was in the front of
my mind but that said my point here is
only that you can just keep if you if
you start playing this game you're gonna
find that
great contributors to human culture are
going to be off limits so you should you
should be aware of that and as I say
it's very important to separate the art
from the artist
um I do think that there is a potential
with Kanye because I don't know that
these are strongly held beliefs it's
hard to get inside of his head but I
think there's a possibility where if you
take an example of somebody like
uh Abe foxman famously
um kind of privately approached Jesse
Jackson in 1984 after Jesse Jackson had
made really anti-semitic remarks and
famously called New York Jaime town he
you know defended Louis Farrakhan things
like that and it took a while but
eventually foxman was able to sort of
change help to change Jesse Jackson's
heart through appealing to him and
talking to him I don't see why you
couldn't have
you know a Barry Weiss or somebody like
that today on these Jewish issues and
saying this is why it's really offensive
to Jewish people or me I don't know
someone to kind of meet with him and say
you know I know you said this stuff and
I'm not trying to cancel you I'm not
trying to go after you I'm trying to say
do you really think this because you
know I really love your music and there
is a way that maybe you can I I don't
see this as somebody who has deeply held
beliefs now I want to address one of the
things that Oneness which is let's steal
Manic from the other side
uh in this day and age of celebrity
culture someone like Kanye West has you
know what tens of millions hundreds of
millions of people who listen to his
music and really look up to him and the
argument would be that when he says it's
okay uh when he gives he gives a certain
legitimacy to Classic anti-semitic
tropes or conspiracy theories and that
is dangerous because he's got so many
people who adore him for his music
my response to that is you have a very
low opinion of Kanye West fans which is
to say that you don't think that Kanye
West fans or at least most of them can
distinguish between goofy stuff that he
says
whether it's offensive or just crazy and
his music do you think that
music fans are automatons and they're
waiting for like you know the secret
instructions and then you're gonna have
50 million people who are anti-semitic
that's nuts I don't think that's how
life works I don't think how celebrity
culture really works and while it might
be that there's some people who feel
that this is a permission structure I
think it's probably a slim slim minority
of it I I I uh you know sort of raised
this earlier this morning when I had a
haircut in my Barbershop and I said well
what do people think of all this stuff
because you know it's not just the
anti-semitic stuff you have the white
lives matter all this other things and
it was like you know the the general
consensus in my barber shop was
he's lunching but it doesn't change the
fact that his music is really great you
know yeah of course he says that he's a
crazy artist it happens and I would
imagine most people probably think that
way but it is important to sort of
understand that when you have somebody
with that much cultural pull that it it
can mainstream you know ideas that
should be Fringe and and uh and you know
quarantined I suppose if uh you know one
thing to uh think about with that too
Eli is that people will say that about
music stars uh in a way that they don't
about say novelists or poets like you
know the argument again says repound who
obviously was never popular in the way
that Kanye West is popular but we can
talk about somebody like Alice Walker
whose Color Purple is probably a book
that you know as many Americans are as
alive have read The Color Purple as have
read any other novel I mean you know
it's a major major work she has
trafficked in anti-semitic uh you know
tropes or so elf as well as is a
believer of David Ike the former soccer
now you know soccer player announcer
turned a theorist of a grand conspiracy
of lizard people including the royal
family of England as well as Dana Perino
at Fox News and other assorted gems are
really running the planet while Mass you
know while hiding Retreat lizard quality
but very few people would say you
shouldn't read the color purple or even
other things that Alice Walker said uh
you know we we attribute a lot more
intelligence to non-music fans
um it's a really great Point yeah yeah
you know and and to a certain degree
maybe movie stars but even them not as
much and that's a kind of fascinating
thing which I hadn't really thought
about until you were talking about this
because we don't
um you know we don't we don't go after
you know high-class people
um you know uh somebody like Gertrude
Stein had many many kind things to say
say about the patan regime the Vichy
collaborationist regime of which she was
a guest you know during World War II and
that's only recently come to light in
literary studies where people are
grappling with the fact that Stein in
certain ways supported a regime you know
or a political movement that also saw
her as one of the great enemies of
Western Civilization
celebrated the Islamic revolution in
Iran he to his credit uh you know he uh
he denounced it shortly after that and I
mean you can yes you can you can it you
know it's an open question as to whether
or not somebody who falls for that in
the first place is kind of you know is
he worth thinking through but uh but you
know certainly he's no Martin Heidegger
you know to give another example who was
an open Nazi never never hid it uh and
you know people still did Carl Smith
they affected that yeah so I mean that
that's an interesting question and I am
you know what seems to be a little bit
different now and this might be a
positive thing because in the 90s and
you know I started a reason in 93 and
and that was a decade where liberals and
conservatives but especially people like
Hillary Clinton were attacking uh and
Janet Reno uh the Clinton Administration
more probably were attacking
um cable TV and music for its pernicious
effects in video games which were
emerging as a kind of art form in a very
popular Entertainment form they attacked
them from the specific grounds that you
were saying Eli you know that people
watch them and they do what they see
that audiences are essentially you know
trained monkeys who you know they see
something on the TV and they go out and
do it
um I think it might be a positive sign
that we're not talking about this in you
know quite in these terms I don't think
people are saying uh uh Kanye West is
legitimizing anti-Semitic violence it's
just I don't want to listen to that guy
because he's empty semi and that's by
the way if an individual if a Jewish
person or somebody who is offended by
any of you if that's what you decide
that's fine I mean I don't think that
that's like I'm not going to necessarily
be critical I do think that
you you know that there's we we've
covered why that's a problem
consistent in that view I do think too
like a lot of the time like this I think
it was back in 2019 uh Nick Cannon was
also like received like uh the same kind
of pushback that Kanye's getting now for
some anti-semitic uh quotes and then of
course um this happened to Dave
Chappelle too
um he had he said our I think it was
part of his Netflix special that you
know was controversial for other reasons
as well
um and I think they all addressed it in
other ways of like oh I need I need to
learn more I need I like I will I will
be better next time I just I'm not
convincing I don't think Dave Chappelle
did that no no that's what Nick Cannon
did not danger yeah yeah I'm just I'm
not convinced that Kanye is going to do
that
um I think I think part of it too is
that like this all stemmed from like his
interview on Tucker was after the he
wore the White lives matter shirt at
Paris fashion week uh last week with uh
Candace Owens um which she 100 knew was
going to be provocative and uh going to
be controversial let's let's run the
clip him talking about wives White lives
matter
um and then we'll pick up the
conversation all right uh wearing the
Hat I had a uh someone call me last
night and said anybody wearing a white
lives matter shirt is going to be green
lit and that means that they're going to
beat them up if they wear it and I'm
like you know okay green like me then
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
so he just he was receiving uh obviously
a ton of backlash
a Paris fashion week and of course
Candace Owens came to his defense on
Twitter
um but there was like so many events
that just like cascaded off of that
um so as the White lives matter t-shirt
then it um I believe it was he uh posted
tweets or no posted text messages from
Diddy
um and about Diddy wanted to like meet
with Kanye face to face and have a
conversation about the white lives
matter t-shirt
um they go way back and then uh Kanye
just like kind of spiraled from there
then got invited onto Tucker
um and I think giving given all the
context like I don't necessarily think
this is someone that's like oh like we
can change his mind or like he'll learn
in the long run
um not that I don't say that's for
everyone but Kanye I'm just not
convinced that like from Eli's uh like
what Eli was saying earlier that he's
going to like we can like alter his mind
by like making him learn more
I mean just like it's often times if you
want to change someone's mind you don't
do it in a public way where you try to
get clout for criticizing them you meet
with them privately and you kind of try
to you try to connect with somebody on a
human level
and that's far more effective in dealing
with an individual celebrity who says
Terrible Things
um versus
you know what we do now which is that
there's a whole bunch of people who are
rushing to kind of cancel somebody and
make sure that you know we no longer
celebrate them and the whole idea we're
going to de-platform them in the
internet era I mean that makes no sense
you know but okay fine
why don't we uh let's run the
um anti-Semitism clip that we have
Natalie and then come back to the
conversation and this is Kanye talking
to uh Tucker again and where he gets
into a kind of classic uh anti-semitic
Trope and also the
this is one of the clips that
was so Vice had picked it up
Planned Parenthood was made by Margaret
Sanger
a known Eugenics with the KKK
to control
the Jew population when I say Jew I mean
the 12 lost tribes of Judah the blood of
Christ who
the race the people known as the race
black really are this is who our people
are the blood of Christ this as a
Christian is my belief and I believe
that if we saw ourselves as more
there you go
uh do you want to uh burrow into that a
little bit Eli uh what is the what's
what's he getting at first of all isn't
it always the case that there's like a
little bit of
true fact mixed in with a bunch of
[ __ ] like it's always like that's
how conspiracy theories work because it
is true that Margaret Sanger really was
concerned about minority populations and
like that's that's a real thing there
were a whole bunch of progressives at
the beginning of the 20th century that
embraced Eugenics from a kind of you
know we're doing it for their own good
kind of perspective and that was really
awful and we denounced it today and it
was part of you know I I will rushed to
point out that uh Margaret Sanger though
herself uh was very anti-abortion she
believed in contraception but not
abortion and it's kind of fascinating to
me you know that Planned Parenthood
claims her in one way
um even though she was anti-abortion and
conservatives hate her even though she
was anti-abortional that's a very good
crazy mixed number no that's what I'm
saying that like this is like you know
this was also this is the same tree that
gave us like the kind of scientific
racism and right you know social
Darwinism and all these ideas that are
now been discredited but it was a thing
that was you know it's part of our
history and then if of course he layers
on top of that Fiction and Fantasy and
and it is an anti-semitic Trope it's not
one as a Jew that I have to tell you
that I am you know it's not on the top
of my list of concerns because it is so
nutty and the mainly the people who
believe it are the like you know the
black Israelites who you see it you know
Union Station or something at the
Lincoln Memorial
right exactly like it's so it's you know
and you have to and the Nation of Islam
certainly Louis Farrakhan is trafficked
in that quite a bit now I can remember
as I'm sure you do Eli a particular
moment in the mid 90s when I think it
was Khalid sheikhma not Khalid Sheikh
Muhammad Khalid Muhammad who was
affiliated with the Nation of Islam gave
a speech where he talked about uh you
know Bagel eating hook nose so-called
Jews at Kane college and he would refer
to Rudy Giuliani the mayor of New York
is Adolf Giuliani yeah and whatnot
um and got cashier got cashiered out of
the Nation of Islam because of that yeah
so listen that's these are kind of
deplorable ideas but again
um I do think that sometimes we have a
problem in our society of what I call
like the weak fascist problem which is
to say when there are minority groups
that don't have real cultural economic
or political power but have deplorable
and terrible ideas
um we we have to make a distinction
between that and then like you know
Jim Crow south of when you have powerful
local government institutions that are
that are driven by a certain kind of
racist ideology so again I am like more
concerned with the official state
ideology of Iran that wants a nuclear
weapon than I am with a bunch of you
know so-called black Israelites who
believe much garbage about you know the
Lost tribes of Israel and so forth well
can I ask then I mean that's that's
really provocative and by the way if uh
you know that it that kind of informs my
critique of
um of To Kill a Mockingbird which is a
novel which is always celebrated but it
strikes me you know what What To Kill a
Mockingbird does is it ends up putting
the onus of of uh segregation in the
south on the backs of poor whites you
know who are incestuous Etc they didn't
have power it was the power elite it was
the Atticus finches of the world and
everybody He piled around with who were
the problem in the South you know
ultimately because they held power so I
I like the way that you're talking about
weak fascists we build build up people
who don't have the kind of power because
they're easy pickings and we can kind of
slay them it's related to this but I
mean one of the reasons why I am not on
the like emergency of democracy and like
once I think January 6 was terrible yeah
but January 6 was largely a problem you
had one guy the president who did tried
to steal an election which is horrible
but then all the people who are being
punished who show up at the Capitol who
think they're actually going to overturn
the election are the disenfranches they
have no real power and they're that's an
example of kind of like the weak Fascism
and like to treat them like Al Qaeda
after 9 11 I think is a category error
which we're doing right now so then let
me ask though I I thank you that's I
think that's a great Insight what kind
of power does Kanye West have you know
and he doesn't have the power of Bull
Connor or you know something he's not
going to be setting dogs loose on Jews
or you know white people or Taylor Swift
fans or anything like that but doesn't
he have some kind of cultural power or
how do we measure the influence that you
know that he has or artists like him
um because we want to admit I mean we
don't don't we don't want to confuse
them you know with you know with people
with guns and badges necessarily but you
know aren't they unacknowledged
legislators of the world as uh you know
Shelley talked about poets I mean what
what is his cultural power that
and Natalie do you want to say something
yeah I think I mean I think Kanye has a
like a significant amount of Social
Capital right
um and obviously his power comes through
um through social capital and like
I think it was yesterday I was looking
this up but um he might not be he's
obviously not getting celebrated for
these comments on Twitter but apparently
for Chan and like some of and some of
those other sites are like blowing up
about how he is like uh like a
conservative icon because of these
comments not because of like his support
for Trump but because of these comments
so there are like there are bigoted
people that like see this as validation
um for their beliefs and he and that's
where he's pulling a lot of that Social
Capital
um now do I think like do I think he
is like is dangerous
like like vote to the level that like
Eli was saying with like some of his
other examples no
um but I think at the same time like
this man very much believes he will be
president in his lifetime he said that
it like in the Tucker Carlson interview
and like you know we we said he's going
he's clearly going through
um a tough battle with mental illness
and whether there's debates or whether
or not he's like you know that has highs
and lows and whether he's in a high
right now
um but I think like someone who that is
that sure they're going to be president
in their lifetime well one someone who
wants to be president period is you know
always questionable but
um I think that I think he has a lot
more Social Capital than people are
giving him credit for because they're
they're writing him off as crazy yeah
does that can we separate out yeah can
we separate out the idea that like he's
crazy because he likes Trump which seems
to be part of what's going on or he's
crazy because he is struck struggling
with bipolar disorder and has you know
in the past acknowledge such I mean one
of the things that I find and I I don't
know that there's any meaningful way to
disentangle this but like it bothers me
that we at times increasingly it seems
we're willing to pathologize people's
political beliefs
um you know and and not simply say
you're wrong but like you're nuts
I mean I think I think among especially
among uh younger people in general
mental health is like is a really
important thing that a lot of
politicians probably aren't taking as
seriously as they should especially as
my generation the generation below me
gets gets a little bit older
um it's it's in the Forefront of like
all all of the polls are like for
younger people under 25 the biggest
concern they have is you know mental
health like taking care of their mental
health mental health illnesses not
having enough like support in you know
in college and high school whatever
um to treat mental health problems
um so I think it's I I certainly I I do
not think he's crazy because he support
he likes Donald Trump
um I but I do think there there needs to
be some
some like I don't know if it's like an
asterisk or caveat or what
um that hit just because he believes
some things that people you know on the
left or even on the right think it think
is crazy it can't all be attributed to
his mental illness
um and I think mental health is like a
big problem we and clearly in the
unedited Clips we saw
there are some things that like even
Tucker Carlson didn't think were uh yeah
let's say uh kosher enough to show uh
that's a loaded term when you're talking
about Kanye West let's let's I want to
go uh in in just a second to the
question about journalism like are there
questions about how journalism is
practiced particularly by Tucker Carlson
uh you know in in light of this
interview and particularly the stuff he
left out but before we leave this mental
health question Natalie what what do you
think explains you're absolutely right
that you know all polls show that
younger Millennials and gen Z people uh
you know mental health is the concern
that comes up again and again in every
context in every survey and every poll
why is that because I got to tell you I
mean like and you know and I say I've
I've a son who's 28 one who's 21 so it's
not like I'm I'm not talking to people
of in that age cohort but like why is
mental health so front and center
because you know from where I'm sitting
I mean there are many many problems in
the world but it looks pretty [ __ ]
good compared to to 30 years ago
certainly 60 or 80 years ago
going to therapy or the idea of like
actually talking with someone you love
and respect over like stuff you're
struggling over is much less stigmatized
than it used to be
um and I do think like there is more of
an emphasis at
um in schools to kind of like especially
after the covid years and
um isolation to kind of make sure you're
prioritizing you know yourself and your
mental health
um and I think when it was such on
display
with Kanye I think it was like not that
it was triggering um but I think it was
like oh you know maybe there should be
there should be someone that like I
don't know if it steps in or like I
don't I don't necessarily think like
I think Tucker was almost using like it
was very clearly to me that he was like
using Kanye
um and what seemed like a vulnerable
moment
um and then kind of like used it to his
Advantage especially I mean like Nick
said earlier what they cut out almost
says more than what the what the actual
interview did
um so I think I I think it's just like I
think it's a much bigger I wouldn't say
it's more rampant like mental illness or
like people struggling with their mental
health I would just say it's um it's
talked a lot about more talked about
more in public than it used to be
Eli you recently became a parent for the
first time uh do you look forward to a
world in which you know mental health
continues to deteriorate
um no uh and I'm worried that we created
these amazing devices which are
important you know like smartphones and
social media platforms and so forth but
I think they also sort of make us more
miserable and so I it is it is it's it
it's it is like this double-edged sword
you know on the one hand Natalie your
your generation should be delighted if
you take the Long View
you know I mean we just had a plague and
in less than a year we came up with a
vaccine
you know I'm sure you know people who
suffered from the bubonic variety a
thousand years ago would would love to
trade places with us on the other hand I
do think that we're kind of it's like
um the Obesity problem in this country
you know we are a species that's
designed to Crave fat and sugar because
when we were living in you know the Wild
and you know trying to hunt and gather
for our meals
when we've came across such things it
was important because we may not know
what our next meal is and now that we've
figured out how to make ourselves happy
and eat what we like we've created a new
set of problems and I do think that
there's there's some of that as well
uh you know the other thing that I would
add to this
um is I do think that we are
pathologizing everyday life in a way
that is distinct and this is
fundamentally a byproduct of wealth
um more mental you have more mental
problems when you have more choices and
more options including not to work and
I'm not minimizing the struggles that
people have but
um I think one of the most important
books of the past 50 years
um is Christopher lashes the minimal
self which was kind of sequel to his
book the culture of narcissism and he
talks about you know psychic psychic
struggles in an age of diminishing
expectations and he was talking
primarily about the late 70s and a kind
of long slide in in the post-war era
into stagflation and into malaise and
whatnot
um and I think it's actually even more
appropriate now but I I am struck by the
number I have a a lot of friends who are
therapists and counselors and even they
start to talk about like basic kind of
adolescent Rites of Passage not as
something that everybody goes through
but rather as traumas that need to be
taken care of in a way that is very
distinct from how I grew up and I I
would not wish my childhood which I
think was very typical very modal for a
very late baby boomer I wouldn't wish
that on anybody it was a life that was
filled or a a moment that was filled
with a lack of empathy and a lack of
interest in people's interior lives and
all of that very intolerant of
difference and individualism in profound
ways but I think we may have gone too
far in a different direction where it's
like you know every disappointment that
is part of growing up has become a
trauma that needs to be treated and
Natalie to your point I think not only
have we destigmatized mental uh mental
health uh issues which is good we've
also probably created a lot more because
there's so much more money flowing into
kind of therapy and help and lash talks
about how even people like Victor Frankl
who wrote a man's life for meaning or
Man's Search for meaning after surviving
a concentration camp that he that's
somewhere in the post-war era the
Concentration Camp experience actually
became kind of a paradigm from which to
view everyday life and he has This
brilliant uh kind of uh passage in the
minimal self where he talks about how
everybody started talking about
themselves as survivors which was a term
that was originally uh you know
signified only people who had survived
death camps and then suddenly it was you
know if you uh if you escape from
Mormonism you were a Survivor if you did
this you were a Survivor et cetera and
we still hear that rhetoric and I think
we need to you know kind of have a
recalibration of what is actually
traumatic and what is Simply Life as we
know it you know I I just if I could
I think it's useful if you're if you're
a Generation Z person
and you're feeling a lot of anxiety
you know in in instead of you know kind
of you know thinking about the therapist
or taking time off
take some time
and get a book out about the siege of
Stalingrad
or watch a documentary like showa
and then appreciate
the sort of extremes of The Human
Condition
and that might have an effect of sort of
making you feel like you know what maybe
I don't have it so bad yeah I think a
big thing too
that they touch on
odds are as you know as private or as
public as we want to make them and
that's how like all celebrities live
their lives as well
um so I think that's a big change too is
that you know we're seeing we're the
Kanye West of 2005 we didn't have I mean
we had tabloids but we didn't have like
uh instant access to him on Twitter and
like his stream of Consciousness at 2
A.M that he was tweeting yeah um and I
think that that's a that's a big
difference too and like uh I think
another thing that you know makes it a
little different like I do think there
is some Credence to what Nick was saying
in the sense that like we have we gone
too far about addressing like uh younger
younger children's mental health or like
do we need to uh take a step back
because that's like that's a big thesis
and the coddling of the American mind
right
um and how
um the younger Generations aren't like
we're still kind of seeing the effects
of them uh you know being cuddled
um and
I think you know I had uh I grew up the
youngest of four like I I had a great I
have a great family and I have I was
lucky to have very supportive parents
and I think that goes a lot further
um and goes a lot further than trying to
like address these issues uh you know uh
broadly or like through social media
than anything else I I think you raise a
lot of points and you know one of the
reasons we might not have heard from
Kanye for a while particularly even if
he was seething about not being able to
talk about the support for Donald Trump
ironically was Kim Kardashian his you
know his wife who has since said you
know like you know it's hard living with
a guy who's struggling with this uh with
bipolar but she's one of the change
agents as well who really has taken a
personal life and you know aired
everything and it's obviously it's
curated she's in charge of most of the
messages she's sending but that's a
radically different world yeah well she
thinks she is and you know and it's
fascinating when you think about
somebody like her who emerges into the
public Consciousness through a sex tape
and then becomes you know either
Kardashians Keeping Up with the
Kardashians is back on Netflix now or
Hulu uh for a new you know set of uh
runs this it's a different world than we
were in you know certainly 20 years ago
uh or even 20 years ago much less 40 or
50 years ago
um let's uh and I would also recommend
people you know the coddling in the
American mind is a is a really
fascinating and important book one
criticism I would have of is that it it
seemed to start blaming students and
like it starts with that moment really
at Yale in what was it 2014 when a bunch
you know and Greg Luciano and Jonathan
Heights say you know what changed was
for a long time the administrators of
colleges and you know universities were
pushing stuff on kids that were pushing
speech codes and restrictions and then
suddenly what flipped was that the
students were demanding it and it turned
into a kind of like Red Guard moment
where young revolutionaries were
silencing the adults I don't doubt that
I mean I think that's accurate but it
also kind of uh mitigates the role that
adults played in creating this and I
would recommend people read Carla
vermeulen's generation disaster which
talks about people born between 1990 and
2001 and the messages that they have
been getting since in utero of you know
that the environment is destroyed the
planet is dead and over you're going to
be shot at a school shooting you're
going to be kidnapped you're going to be
killed by Islamic terrorists the
financial system has collapsed the
housing market has collapsed there are
no jobs anymore Donald Trump is evil and
then covet and it's a really interesting
look at the overall cultural messages
that are not coming from younger people
people they're being pushed that's the
you know the media that's the water
people are swimming in and it fills it's
a very good compliment to uh to the
cuddling the American mind let's in in
the last bit that we have together here
let's talk about the question of
Journalism that is raised by the Tucker
Carlson
um interview uh and I guess Natalie
let's go to to you first on this you
know when you look at what was aired and
you know when I first looked at the the
interview I thought you know Kanye for
the most part he seemed very low you
know he was very loquacious and
interesting and engaged and kind of
smart and and winning in many ways then
when you look at the outtakes you're
like wow this is like really heavily and
clearly edited in order to lose the
crazy
um does that present a journalistic
ethics question or or is this just more
of like you know caveat Lecter let the
reader beware you know we always know
we're being played but you know what's
your takeaway on that I mean I do think
I do think there is a valid conversation
going on about like whether or not that
interview should have been aired at all
if they cut out some of the after seeing
some of the parts that were cut out
um I but I mean I personally think
Tucker knew and that Tucker's team knew
that they were going to get a
provocative interview and like that's
what they wanted and they I think I
don't think this is right but they just
kind of like were didn't necessarily
care about Kanye's state of being
um and to them I mean the more are not I
guess not the more crazy but the more
like provocative and thought-provoking
that he was the better it was for them
um I do think that is a little bit I
think that's vicious um I do think you I
do think Kanye was used
um in that in that regard uh I also
think I think it was totally okay some
people are saying that you know the vice
over uh motherboard over at Vice
shouldn't have um published the unedited
Clips I completely disagree I think they
should publish them because it gave us
context
um and I think it's a very important
context and it was more honest than the
Carlson uh show was was being
um and I I do see the argument that
you're like oh well my my advice
publishing that is just like
perpetuating the problem and that kind
of thing but that was context that I
think everyone needed
um to know like the grounds and when
that interview went down because the way
Tucker painted it was like oh we only
asked for a 30 minute interview and we
got two hours of great footage like he
touted like the that in the very
beginning of the show
um and that's not at all how it appeared
to what went down I mean even in some of
the unedited Clips Kanye said like
controversial things and then like was
clearly like rambling and like flustered
and then was like actually can you edit
that out like he was clearly frustrated
trying to find his words
um right and I think that gave
incredible context and I think it was
totally okay for vice to publish that
stuff because
I mean Carlson was never going to admit
to that being being the situation Eli as
a journalist uh you look upon this and
do you despair like Ozymandias or uh no
um TV this is this this goes on in TV
interviews all the time especially when
you're talking about celebrities as
opposed to politicians but it happens
with politicians too there'll be two
hours or three hours of raw material you
have to cut it down you know because
we're not talking about the internet now
we're talking about an actual show that
only has you know an hour time slot
I guess I'm not that surprised I'm
totally with you Natalie that uh it's
okay to
you know the more the better
um it's probably good that the world
sees the
um nuttier parts that were left on The
Cutting Room floor because I think it
does give a fuller picture of
you know this is this is where Kanye's
at right now in his life and I do think
of that actually in a weird way
mitigates the anti-semitic stuff that he
said so
you know it's important everybody should
denounce that wow that's a really crazy
theory that the people who call
themselves Jews are not Jews that's
really wrong don't do it okay fine but
it's again like I just think that most
people who like Kanye West's music can
distinguish between his music and then
like what he is saying even if he has
delusions of grandeur that he will be
president one day
um I just think most people kind of can
see it for themselves
maybe on you know whistling past the
graveyard maybe I'm being pan gloss here
and I should be more upset as a Jewish
person about anti-Semitism but I just
can't I'm not gonna you know I think
what he said is terrible but
you know it's also we have all the
context now and we understand that he's
going through he's going through it he's
going through it right now he's going
through a tough time I think he he
believes things that are not you know
real he's maybe having it at times a
little bit of a break in reality
I mean it's also important I think it's
important to note too that like there
have been all these articles that have
come out since this interview trying to
like assess his mental state yeah all of
these uh doctors in to be like well this
is could be what he's experiencing or
this is what but living with bipolarity
is like and I mean it ultimately comes
down to like everyone's like psychiatric
state is their own and they're all
different everyone experiences it
manifests differently manic breaks
manifest differently and I think like
okay if you're you're going to try and
help people understand why Kanye might
be saying some of this stuff and he
might be like acting erratic and all
those types of things
um and I do think those articles
certainly help but I think like when it
ultimately when it comes down to it at
the end of the day he's the only one
that hopefully understands the mental
state that he's in and hopefully you
know working on
working on himself just like all of us
are but I think like like we even we
didn't touch on this yet but there was
like a comment he made about him
believing that you know fake children
were put into his house to
um like are like I guess fake friends of
his children were put into his house to
like influence his children
um and there was like just some other
like really disturbing things that
I I you just like you're like wow like
it illuminated how how much these are
these are Hallmarks of a of a kind of
paranoia and delusion that often goes
along with something like bipolar or
Mania uh in in an older formula I think
that's right and and I think that's
correct I would I just would recommend
for people watching this Freddie Deborah
has written about specifically Kanye but
also we Freddie's own personal accounts
of his bipolar disorder and what he had
to go through
um I mean I think Freddie is a great
writer even though I disagree when I
even when I disagree with him he's a
socialist but um I think he's a terrific
writer and he writes really well about
his own bipolarity and his own his own
mental health issues
and you know it's fair to say that when
you're in the grips of something like
that you're not yourself
I think that's fair I think that's a
fair point and it's possible that we're
seeing Kanye right now but it's not him
it's not the real Kanye and hopefully
there are people in his life who love
him and
will understand that and accept that
this is you know this is not who he is
it's not as true yeah and you know it's
interesting because we uh you know in
this this is a move that goes back to
the beginning of time but I know in
American literature it's you know at
least from the early 1800s where we
always you know we always insist that at
this moment we are the wisest that we
will ever be and that we look at the
near pass or the distant past and so
they were just benigned it because they
aren't as smart as us and Natalie to
your point like we are much more
sophisticated when it comes to mental
health issues but the fact of the matter
is is that like most people don't know
anything about what it means to be in
the grip of like a serious mental
illness
um and as a result like a lot of the
interpretation of it I think you know
veers into you know just a kind of cheap
castigation or dismissal of somebody
when in fact they are you know they are
not themselves I mean that's a kind of
profound thing to to kind of talk
philosophy like that you know when you
are at your most Manic and when you
might be most prone to saying No this is
the real me finally these scales have
fallen from my eyes you know and I know
the truth that is actually not you and
most of the time when you say that
that's a sign that you really need to
check yourself in somewhere
um but um you know we are we'll continue
to have these kinds of conversations
about Madness and civilization and
whatnot um by the way it's not uncommon
I mean I just you know
the great jazz uh alto saxophone player
Charlie Parker had periods of his life
where he would sort of show up in front
of a mental hospital without being
completely naked and just be like okay
I'm here and you know the difference is
that we didn't have social media in
those days but I'm sure if you caught
bird or some of these other great
artists who have similar kinds of
conditions
at their height of their manicness they
would probably be saying a lot of things
too and the issue really is that it's
not oh my God you know the guy who made
College Dropout hates the Jews ugh you
know I don't think that's what it is you
know what I mean because it's like it's
so tossed off and nutty
as opposed to like there are people who
spend a lot of time constructing
anti-semitic conspiracies and tropes
right and that's much more Sinister in
my view than than what Kanye West and
maybe I'm influenced because I love his
music and I love his art but I really do
think there is a difference there
I think there's also a difference uh in
this to an earlier point in the
conversation to think about how do we
comp you know rather than uh and
obviously everybody is free to either
listen to or read or watch or whatever
they want or not right you know there's
no moral imperative here but to
complicate history and the failings or
the proclivities of of creators and
authors so
um you know somebody like Arthur Kessler
who is widely regarded for you know
writing a classic anti-uh anti-communist
book uh Darkness at noon was a serial
rapist uh almost certainly and murdered
his wife before committing suicide and
when you see that I mean one you know a
legitimate response I think is to be
like you know what I I I can get what's
good in Kessler from somewhere else I'm
not going to bother reading him but it
complicates uh things there's a uh an
Italian novelist who wrote The Great
anti-fascist novel Ignacio Salone who
wrote a book called bread and bread and
wine and it turned out he was a
communist in Italy during uh Mussolini
during fascism and it turned out that he
was both an agent of the common turn of
the Soviet International uh he was also
informing uh on his communist you know
partisans to the fascist government and
reporting to the U.S so he was a triple
agent and he wrote this great novel
which was about people who get sold out
by uh you know by double agents and it
you know it makes the work more
interesting in my mind rather than less
interesting if you reduce it to a kind
of morality tale
um stabbed his wife
yeah well that you know that is
interesting like there's not I don't
know that that complicates you know
because he actually talks about what
what is interesting about that is you
know he stabbed her right when he was
announcing that he was running for mayor
of New York and in Louis manan's uh
recent book The Free World which is a
cultural history of post-war America he
talks about how the New York
intellectual sign even people like Diana
trilling all sided with Norman mailer
James Baldwin said uh you know what like
the the woman kind of deserved it and
that complicates things where it's like
it does you know but but it's you know
the history is not a morality tale it is
you know it's a garbage pail and you
rummage through a lot of it and pieced
together a narrative that kind of makes
sense or doesn't depending on what you
need
um just uh to I don't think we're going
to get to questions uh but uh just to uh
sum up uh Natalie what is uh you know
what do you do tomorrow
after this conversation and after Kanye
West talking to Tucker Carlson and all
that what you know what's what's your
what's what's the thing that you take
that will help you live a better life
tomorrow
um you know I mean I'm gonna still
listen to Kanye West music I love some
of his original albums um it's not gonna
change it but I am I'm gonna you know
look a little closer especially like I
when when you think about cultural icons
that you really like love and cherish
um you you think about like there's a
whole part of them and a whole life you
don't see that they have um and I think
it's it's important to be you know
thoughtful about the type of the
cultural icons that you love and the
ones that you follow
um and I think this is just another like
you know litmus test of who who you look
up to no that's kind of what I told from
it Eli
I hope uh Kanye uh kind of Records a
remix of Patika that would be that would
be like the perfect are you gonna wrap
we're gonna rap with him I'm gonna rap
with him why do you have to do this Nick
anyway
um no I I don't know I mean I'm not
gonna I
again like I I think we should get to
this point in our culture where we're
not looking at our
at our musical heroes or artistic Heroes
for our political guidance or something
or like you know what we think of other
things we can we should be able to
distinguish that and I think that's the
grown-up position it's like you wrote
this great piece Nick and I it stayed
with me that like why are we why do we
want our presidents to also be our
preachers like why do we want them to be
our like moral exemplars right
yeah we're we're hiring them for a job
so to speak and like let's let's stay in
your lane like we don't have to be all
these other things and I kind of feel
the same way about
you know great artists or you know kind
of people who are are celebrities like
we should be we should it's part of
being
you know in a free Society is do you
have to be kind of a participant and you
have to be a grown-up and not not assume
that everybody else's children
I think uh that's those are two good
insights I'll throw in mine which is
that this whole episode
reminds me we live in a in a golden age
of kind of forced transparency and so
the you know the the Fox news interview
with Tucker Carlson is one thing and I'm
kind of glad that you know that it's out
there I don't know that you can really
take advantage of a superstar like Kanye
West uh but the the fact that Vice aired
other things you know basically what has
been you know over the past 20 or 50
years it's harder and harder to hide
stuff but what remains after that is
that people who are generally acting in
good faith and are kind of honest and
admit their mistakes and move on or grow
you know generally do pretty well in the
world and you know one of the other
things is that just as as consumers and
we're all consumers in you know in a
media age like we're in now you need to
be really um thoughtful and and you know
everybody needs to have media literacy
cranked up to 11. because what you're
seeing is never really the truth and you
always have to create the own your own
context and meaning for it and and I
think this episode kind of helps uh you
know for sure underscore that
I want to thank uh Natalie dausicki of
Reason uh for joining me on this live
stream as well as Eli Lake Eli your uh
your podcast is yeah listen to the
re-education uh where where's the best
place to listen to it no apple we're on
all the platforms but listen to it we've
got this week we've got
uh a great episode with Jamie kirchuk on
the Lincoln project and the one tomorrow
will be all about the sort of nuclear
bringsmanship right now over Ukraine and
Vladimir Putin it'll be a fun one all
right well thank you all for watching
and listening and participating so all
right so long thank you